The architecture of the Andrew System looks like this. There are client
workstations, which are called virtues. And these client workstations,
are connected by insecure network links, to a local
area network. And through the local area network, they can access servers,
S1, S2, S3 and so on. And these servers are in a secure
environment or in other words, accessing the servers from a client work station
uses insecure links but once inside the boundary of the servers, the servers
can talk to one another, exchange information, grab data from the disks and
so on. This communication that happens inside
this server environment is a secure communication.
That's part of the reason they've named the server environment as Vice, and,
the client environment, where you're accessing information
from the secure servers, as the Virtue
workstation. And the important thing to note is the fact that the clients have
to access information from the server over insecure links. What that means is
that in order to make sure that information that is sent
on the wire to the servers or received from the servers to the clients. They
have to be encrypted, since anyone can sniff the packets that are flowing
on these wires. But inside the vice,
the communication that happens among the servers,
because it is secure, there is no need for information encryption. The client
workstations run some flavor of Unix operating
system. So inside each client workstation, there
is a special process called Venus. And this process, which runs on the virtue
workstation, is for the purpose of authentication of the user, and for client
caching of files that the user may fetch from
device servers into the workstation that they're logging in to. The
user will use RPC in order to get the files
that they want to work on, on the workstation. And this is where Venus comes in.
Venus is the one that authenticates a user walking
up to a virtue workstation, to the server and then acting as the surrogate
for the user, in fetching the files that he or she wants to work on from the
file server using RPC. And since I mentioned that the link that is used to
communicate between virtue and vice is insecure. The
RPC has to be a secure RPC. In
other words, the RPC messages, both passing the
parameters and receiving the results, is going to use
encryption on the data that is being sent and
received between the virtue and the vice file server.